hey guys Ryan right here so I am going
to be sharing with you guys something
that Jerry and I created a few years ago
basically we wanted to submit a couple
of horror short films - Halloween Horror
Nights film festival thing we did not
get in just want to tell you that right
now
and after seeing these short films
you'll probably understand why and this
was us
trying to be as serious as possible and
there you know some people think they're
scary some people think they're not but
you know either way like the first one
it actually is with Veronica's sister
Alicia it's in black and white stars me
and her it's like a b-movie horror short
I'm credited as this guy named Greg Alba
don't know why I chose that name and it
was directed by Jerry he Kratz himself
as John Humphrey don't know why I chose
that name the other one is another
horror short that's Jerry directed and I
came up with this story for and co-wrote
it along with very none of us are in
that one but I dig that one more than
the one Amin so yeah enjoy the double
feature our little grindhouse show that
we wanted to share with you guys
you
yes you don't need that Jones brothers
ring anymore
but you're right I don't need it anymore
[Music]
you hear that
I think someone's not gonna do a front
door is a scary
six days ago was our 14th month
anniversary and in that time a year and
two months
Little Richard over here
no sex whatsoever okay I think I love
you more than any man has ever loved a
woman ever was a better then
we sound when I ask you to never ask me
that question again okay
see that's when it comes to you I mean
just look at you there is no comparison
hey can I ask you one one last favor
I come back to the room can you make
sure that you're not like a born-again
virgin thing like that
[Music]
[Applause]
today I had my first date
[Music]
you
I'm a go-getter I go for it for what
okay let's buy it I'm in it for what's
mine
maybe your mind I gotta tell you that
[Music]
and that that was something else
were you saving yourself for me did you
know I sure did first time I saw you I
said that one that belongs to me
you sure can work a copy machine
those little skirts of yours it always
baffled me that nobody ever heard the
low down on you I asked around thank you
that box of yours locked
tighter than a 12 year olds porn
collection those pencil-pushing dick
watts don't do it for you you need
somebody who's gonna put you in your
place maybe it's not your place you
threaten me and tell me what I can and
cannot do you don't do it you got
worming you don't let me you don't stop
me I can feel your slipping candy
[Music]
and I can't live with that it's been fun
I'm sorry I'm sorry
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]